Hello, hello, hello!
Welcome back!
My master, my lady, my...
Hello, hello, hello!
Oh, jeez.
I'm okay!
Hello!
As you can see, we have a little timer here.
We've got nine minutes!
Nine minutes until...
Start time was fast.
I got... Wait, did I even tweet?
I have to be fast.
Or else...
You only have a little bit of time before it starts.
Maybe I didn't.
Maybe I didn't tweet.
Oops.
One second.
Wanted.
I almost mistyped.
Anyway, how are you guys today?
It's kind of cozy.
Another state of play, another ace combat coping.
We don't know.
There might be something.
A crumb!
They're pretty outnumbered though.
I think everybody is winning.
Everything...
Everybody is wanting Bloodborne.
Oh my god!
It's like those YouTube timers.
It's like those YouTube countdowns.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, one second.
Let me turn...
Oh my gosh.
Got jump scared for real.
Holy moly.
What is this soundtrack?
Nevermind.
PP music over here.
I don't want to listen to it.
We'll listen to my own music until we...
Until it's time.
And then of course I'm going to make the screen bigger and everything.
So don't worry about it.
If you're like, it's too small.
I'll make it bigger and I'll get rid of my advertisements.
Don't worry.
I have to show them off like at least once a month.
I have to show them off at least once a month because I never go on my chattings to the maid cafe really.
YouTube countdown jump scare.
I know.
Thank you for 10 months.
Dude, where's my music?
There we go.
Minto, since Valentine's Day coming up, do you want to be my Valentine?
Fill out the form.
Do the summoning spell.
Then we'll see, I guess.
Bye, bye, bye.
MGS Bloodborne Ace Combat, knack three, baby.
What are you hoping for at the show?
I just want to hear anything.
Metal Gear.
It might be all the same stuff that kind of got leaked-ish, but it's still exciting to see.
It's still exciting to see.
I don't know.
I want Bloodborne just so that people will shut up.
It's funny because...
Why are people leaking?
Oh, well, it's like hard to say.
Like, rather, it's a leak in that it was from the PlayStation store, you know?
So it wasn't exactly like...
I work for the company and I link this stuff.
It was like just that it showed up on the PlayStation store.
But...
Yeah.
Astro Bot 2?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, Astro Bot DLC would go insane.
Some more Astro Bot DLC, please.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, they should have like a game of the year Astro Bot DLC.
Hoping for trippy Death Stranding trailers.
You know...
Also, hello everyone.
I thought about Death Stranding 2.
Well, ha, get it?
I mean, as in also.
But...
I know that Kojima's gonna be a South by Southwest, which I was like, oh my gosh, I should go.
I should see if I can go and go to his panel.
But then, I'm gonna be in Japan at the time.
So...
Sad, sad.
Dang it.
Otherwise, I was gonna go.
But...
Ace Combat and Ace Combat.
I know, I was like, oh my gosh, Kojima's gonna be in my neighborhood.
But...
Actually, I've never been to South by Southwest, so I don't know anything.
Ace Combat, anything, please.
It's the 30th.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Oh, we have more than one.
I would love more Ace Combat.
I mean, we heard that.
Hold on, let me fix my chair.
Ouch.
We heard that the Ace Combat devs were...
At the Hornet, so...
Bento's state of play.
Oh, Kiwawa.
Alright, oh.
OMG, hello, cutie.
Hi, cutie.
Hi.
Oh, Kiwawa, are you...
Are you wanting any...
Are you...
Do you have any hopes, any kibou for...
State of play today?
I'm surprised.
I feel like it's kind of...
Late in the day.
I feel like usually it's quite earlier.
But...
Or rather, other directs.
I have no idea why Animal Crossing.
I'm a jork.
Oh, she's jorking it, you guys.
She's just...
She's just jorking it, okay?
Ace...
Crumb of Ace Combat.
Ace Combat!
11 p.m.
here.
Yeah, it's so late!
At least the Nintendo ones are like...
Early, early in the morning.
Which makes it kind of...
Late in Japan, but...
From what I know, they've been going to America...
To do research about aviation.
Since the first Ace Combat.
There are planes.
Oh, I didn't know that.
What are we getting?
Minto Astro Bot DLC?
Oh my gosh.
I'm already in the game.
You know, I'm...
My spirit is there.
The ever-growing list gets larger for the Wisp Valentine's requests.
Should we just make a Wisp fund for things like this?
Fund?
No, I'll put up a thing today...
For you guys to fill out for Valentine's.
Kingdom Hearts news.
Oh my gosh.
I think I saw Leah saying that she wanted Kingdom Hearts news too.
Yeah.
When are we getting more Kingdom Hearts news?
Maybe today?
Probably not.
If we get Kingdom Hearts news today, I'll eat my foot.
Playing nerd.
Oh, I thought you were making a joke, Nan.
Def going to South by Southwest.
Last time I went, I was to see my rapper friend perform.
Now gonna see the goat Kojima.
Stop!
Stop bragging to me!
FOMO.
I have FOMO.
New Sly Cooper game.
I feel like we could get so much...
So many cool things.
Especially if it's like, you know...
Astro Bot reviving the love of certain franchise.
Well, I'm saying Astro Bot.
You know what I mean?
Like, there were certain franchises featured in Astro Bot that you're like, Whoa!
So...
You know.
It could be.
So many things.
Akiba Strip news.
I don't think they will do that here.
But Akiba Strip, I think, is kind of dead.
Also, we only have two minutes.
Or yeah, two minutes.
Akiba Strip.
So there was a game after Akiba Strip 2.
That was Akiba's Beat.
And it basically got rid of all the...
Fun, like, advertisement stuff in it.
I guess they did not have the money for the licensing.
And so, it's just...
It's just not...
It's just...
We can pretend that didn't happen.
I didn't even...
I didn't even play it, honestly.
I was like...
Kind of disappointed.
Mint Metal Gear Collab wins.
If only.
Give us a full-on Ape Escape remake, you cow...
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hey, hey, know enough about MGS3 remake.
Hey, hey, hey.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hey, hey.
We can have both.
Why are we throwing one to the side?
Metal Gear Kingdom Hearts Collab.
No, please.
My brain rots.
I would cut off my pinky finger for Bloodborne 2.
It's funny.
I was supposed to play Bloodborne this week.
I was gonna do it for Valentine's Day.
You know.
But I was just like, I don't know if I should start something.
Okay, hold on.
Let me get ready with my...
Let's get rid of my menu.
Let's make me small.
Move me over here.
Let's get bigger.
Scoot over a little bit more.
We're ready for it.
Oh, what the heck?
Why am I cut off?
There we go.
I'm ready, Freddy.
Legend of Dragoon.
Okay, my music.
Go away.
No music.
Who's Freddy?
Freddy is what your mom called me last night.
Oh my gosh.
It's really... I'm premature.
Scary.
I'm trying to determine the music levels.
Oh, Monster Hunter?
I had no idea just how big the world is.
Is this Monster Hunter?
They don't look anime.
Wild.
Oh.
You can...
The Monster Hunter monsters have such like a specific look about them, I feel, you know?
So I feel like it's quite...
When you see them, you're like, oh yeah, that's a Monster Hunter monster.
But the people...
Now that I think about it, I only know what the cats look like in that series.
I don't know what the people look like in that series.
The cats are so cute though.
I think I was supposed to get a Monster Hunter PR pack.
I wonder if that's still coming.
The bit rate...
Wait, is it on?
Oh, I can do 4K!
Let's go.
Sorry, it's a little...
If I'm a little behind.
Cats!
They're so cute!
Monster Hunter Wild.
That's like so soon.
Spring 2025.
Water.
Congratulations to everybody.
You can be so dapper.
Oh, I love art books.
What gaming platform do you main or are you a jack of all trades?
Maybe I'd like to be jack of all trades because I don't want to limit myself.
We will keep you updated on the title update plan, so please look forward to future information.
We are waiting for the title to be released on February 28th.
We are waiting for you to enjoy it.
I don't need to be a master of anything.
I just want to have fun.
I need to hi-chat.
Hello!
Yeah!
State of play!
Master of what?
Sega!
Sonic?
No.
Wait, is this actually Shinobi?
I like the art style.
I like the art style a lot, actually.
It looks fun.
Is this a remaster or a remake?
It was announced a bit ago.
Oh, okay, okay.
Sega's booking?
I feel like a lot of...
the companies...
have been kind of like...
I don't want to say making a comeback, because some of them never really stopped being good, you know, but...
It does feel like we've been getting more effort put into things as of recent, so...
At least with properties.
Revengeance.
Not revengeance.
Vengeance.
Oh!
Here's Sonic!
Oh yeah.
Oh, he's styling.
I can't believe it's cool to be a Sonic fan again.
I can't believe that we're back.
I think maybe Sonic healed everything.
Being a Sonic fan...
Having it cool to be a Sonic fan again healed the gaming industry.
Sonic is always cool.
Yeah, why is he in a car?
Let the guy rest his legs a little bit.
It wouldn't be fair.
He would...
Ace Combat!
We got it!
Oh my gosh, these maps are insane.
Ah, cute.
Where?
Look at him.
Cross worlds.
Wishlist now.
Oh, I can sign up on the 21st.
Let's go.
Akiba.
I thought the art style makes this look like...
Akiba!
Oh my god, Akihabara!
What is this?
Digimon?
Oh!
Akuma!
I saw him for like two seconds.
Wait, Patamon?
Where's my baby?
Oh yeah!
Digimon story.
Time Stranger!
Hello!
Real people.
Digimon story series is super fun.
It looks good.
But, what I was saying earlier is like...
The graphics at first made it look like a...
Like a Genshin game, you know?
Oh my god, Kingdom Hearts.
Isn't that like...
Genshin games have that like...
That type of shading and all.
What does Sora say?
I don't remember.
Oh my...
The bass in my ears!
Oh my god!
Holy deep!
Hot lady.
Red dress?
Why do they sound familiar?
The voice actor sounds familiar.
Prime, is that you?
Peter Cullen?
Must be Optimus Prime?
No way.
Is it Peter Cullen?
We must...
I hear it now.
I was like...
If it's not, that guy...
That guy could totally do a great...
Optimus Prime.
Lost soul aside...
The guy confused me.
I thought he was gonna be talking about...
The previous game, not this one.
Hi!
Oh!
Like a Dragon!
Sea dog?
Like the streamer?
Oh wow.
No way!
And Diver Diver!
Ichiban's Holiday!
I love Diver Diver!
What the hell?
Oh my god!
What?
A crossover?
What is this?
Portal?
I feel Dave the Diver is so powerful.
They get some wack collage.
Hey man!
Oh my god!
He's here!
Oh?
The Island.
Oh!
Triporium?
Oh my god it's Splatoon!
This is just Splatoon!
I'm tearing up.
This is totally rad music.
I love this.
I wanna go to a WWE themed park.
That'd be great!
I hate it.
Borderlands 4.
Coming to PS5!
Seth!
I'm ready!
Seth.
Let's go!
I
don't really know much about Borderlands.
I just know a lot of cosplayers would do the art style.
I like that kind of stuff.
It's kind of similar to Archer.
Keep it that way?
Is it bad?
I always feel like Borderlands was such a beloved series, no?
The first two games were ok.
Alex, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Yeah, there's no shading.
Ok gameplay, bad story.
Maybe they'll redeem themselves.
If the first two games are good, that's only one game that's bad.
Maybe they'll redeem it in the fourth game.
We're a YouTuber?
That's the first thing I thought of too.
This guy's shirt is kind of insane.
It's like a Chinese style polo and then it's got triangles on it.
What is this?
I don't know how to feel about it.
September 23rd!
He's a magician?
Wait, actually?
Is this Tron?
Oh, it takes two again.
I feel like I remember them announcing this.
Tron!
Mega Man!
This is Mega Man cosplay.
So they're just...
They write stories...
And then the stories become... Why are they here?
But they write the stories and then they go into the stories.
Now they're getting arrested in the stories!
What's going on?
Zoe!
Oh no.
But a lot of people like It Takes Two, right?
So it might be a fun co-op game at least.
Split Fiction.
Oh I was going to say, what if one person is playing like the future world?
Oh no!
Oh my god!
Wait!
Oh no, but oh yes!
Oh it's like... Oh my gosh, wait.
Supermassive's take on Alien?
I might be obsessed with this.
Oh my god.
I love these games you guys.
You can't make me hate them.
They'll never make me hate these games.
I was going to say...
The...about the last game...
Was one person plays the future and one person plays the other one at the same time.
That doesn't seem to be the case.
Anyway, whatever.
I got so excited.
It's Bureau Clock and Zero Gravity!
Oh my god!
It's like, yeah, it's like the thing, yeah.
Directive 80, this has been announced a while ago though, I remember.
This has been out, or not out, but... Ok, October 2nd.
Let's go!
No, they announced this a while ago.
It was?
No!
Freddy Fazbears!
Who are these guys?
Who are you?
Oh, it looks like the guy from Final Fantasy.
Why am I getting like Bendy Ink Machine vibes from this?
Secret of the Mimic?
Is this Freddy Fazbear?
There was not a single Freddy Fazbear!
Cozy Horror?
What?
Where is the cozy part?
In clay?
Look at those designs!
Oh my gosh!
And they have actual gameplay!
Holy moly!
Well, this is not what I expected it to look like at all either.
I expected like a side-scroller.
Oh my god!
Where is the cozy?
Cozy!
Oh god!
Oh my god!
Wow!
This is kind of terrifying.
Where is the cozy?
The Midnight Walk?
Wow!
May 8th!
I like it.
Just a cozy game.
They lied as easily as they breathed.
It feels like the movie 9.
Oh I know!
I never saw that, but I know what you are talking about.
Oh in PS5!
I can play!
Sorry!
Decoy Octopus!
Wait, this is kind of cute actually.
Sorry, I just...
Oh my god, wait, this is Metal Gear!
What?
Wacky Wacky!
I'm losing my mind.
Show me Wang Yuanji!
Wang Yuanji, sorry.
I kind of like her a little bit, but I have some colors.
This is horrible.
Butchered version of her name.
Wacky Wacky!
What the hell?
Today?
Hello!
Oh my god!
No way!
I cannot believe that that is Squid Game.
It ended up actually being Metal Gear.
Smash Boom!
Welcome to Battleship.
I like the little icon too, with the characters.
It's kind of cute.
More Onimusha!
Oh my gosh, they say coming to PS5, but is it like... they are not exclusive, it can't be.
But...captured on PC.
Did it say that?
Did I miss that?
That would be so funny.
That's me.
It was at the bottom!
That's nasty.
That's fine.
No, don't talk about my ship like that!
Yes,
my favorite period Japanese word.
Spoken in the ancient times of Nihon...
Yeah!
The Yabe period.
All Onimusha protags are based on real actors.
Oh really?
You get an arm waifu.
Yeah baby!
That's what I'm talking about!
I've watched this trailer like 50 times.
Wait,
he makes the silliest face.
Oh my god, he's such a unit.
Look how thick this man is.
Do you hear me, Snake?
Oh my god, they all look so good!
Wait, wait, wait!
When Snake jumps off his face, watch out!
Yeah, aim with the iPad-chan!
Yeah!
Oh wait, I forgot about the...Yeah baby!
How could I forget?
The best part.
Oh my god, add more please!
Online!
Online please!
Ah!
I have a thousand questions.
What is this?
No, I didn't think it was Ace Combat because the location didn't look so...you know.
What the hell?
It's a sequel to something, right?
Because they are like why did you come back?
Why does he look like Death Stranding almost?
Oh boss!
Oh!
What is this?
Thank you, Mito.
Even though I've seen the trailer so many times, I'm so glad they showed it.
What is it?
Oh, hell is us.
OK
It looks kind of freaky.
I don't know.
Oh wait, is this...is that Lies of Pea?
Lies of Peek?
Oh, I thought it was Mr. Krabs for a second.
Oh my god!
Wow, hi.
I keep getting Lies of Pea like fan cam edits in my TikTok.
All the comments are always like Lies of Pea, Lies of Pea.
OK, here it looks...I thought it was like a Souls-like game, right?
Let's go!
Yeah, it is like a game.
Overture!
Base game required.
So it's DLC.
So funny.
What is this?
I was going to say this seems cozy, but the guy literally has a...
Huh?
What?
Oh my god!
It's kind of cozy.
I mean, you blow things up and...
No creation without destruction.
Oh my god!
Tecmo murder!
Dreams of another.
Oh my gosh, that game in VR?
Would probably be so weird.
This is just a...
It's just a rage room.
Take off your hat.
No, you might be bald under there.
Hey everyone, I'm Kristen Zitani and I'm excited to share even more PlayStation news in today's show.
Oh yeah, that's why we're here for.
Why is everything getting VR support?
I don't think I want to actually be in the zombie game.
I don't think I want to live that.
I think I'm ok.
Yay!
Oh it's VRR.
I thought she said VR.
Ok.
Oh my god!
Imagine this in VR.
Come on!
Ok.
Oh, Nikkei!
That's not surprising at all actually.
Oh, new outfits!
Well, I know already a handful of people that are very excited about that.
We've got some great PlayStation Plus updates today, starting with game catalog titles arriving on February 18th.
Star Wars Jedi Survivor, Topspin 2K25, and launching in a game catalog Lost Records Bloom and Rage from the creators of Life is Strange.
Bloomerage.
Do you girls ever see anything weird around these parts?
In this episodic adventure, players will join four high school girls living through the defining summer of their lives.
Why do they keep making coming of age games?
This is just Stranger Things.
That's all they know.
They didn't have a good summer in high school.
They keep wanting to make it recreated in a video game.
Everything is a thing of the...
This feels like mist.
Wait, I'm kind of really into this.
Wait no, show me more!
No, I want to see more!
Ew.
Is it good?
This is such a VTuber game.
Meanwhile, Patapon 3 slides its way into the classics catalog next week.
Pretty.
I can sense it.
As long as it is reforged.
The game is pretty.
Wishes.
Jennifer English.
London, close enough, welcome back Bloodborne.
I'm not gonna lie, for like a second I was like...
Gwendolyn.
Maybe some people think it's a granny.
Oh no.
Tides of Annihilation.
In development for PS5.
She's so beautiful.
Ok.
That doesn't seem bad.
That's pretty neat.
These noises.
Vulcan!
Vulcan Raven!
Armstead.
Bro sounds like Raiden.
I think it's... I kinda hear it.
Metal Eden.
Welcome back Metal Gear!
I saw like everything and nothing.
Everything and nothing.
Drone.
Pocket drone!
What is it?
And they said build a rocket game.
Did you actually build the rocket?
What?
Oh my God, Detroit become human!
Let's go!
Detroit become rocket!
What if this was actually GTA 6?
That would be insane.
They have the chance to do the funniest thing right now.
Say GTA 6.
Damn.
Mines...MinesEye.game Hello.
He seems so polite.
He's so...he's standing so tall.
He's so soft spoken.
I know he's really tense.
It's ok buddy, you can relax.
Ok.
Thank you!
He's so chill.
The game is like insane.
He's like, hello, welcome to my game, MinesEye.
You can play it later this year.
We get it, you can drive the car.
Ok, you can blow up the car.
You don't have to drive the car, you can run the car.
You can outrun the car.
I can no longer drive the car.
I must now run from the car.
You can beat the car.
Transformers!
Robots in disguise.
MinesEye.
Transformers.
Robots in MinesEye.
Detroit become car.
What could it be?
Kingdom Hearts.
Kingdom Hearts!
Death Stranding?
Bloodborne?
Peace Combat?
Really?
Oh, so he's a big deal.
Helldivers?
Looks like the uniform.
Oh my god.
I think you gotta get out of there, buddy.
Nevermind.
What?
Well, that's actually kind of really awesome looking.
He looks really good.
Like he does not look uncanny video game.
He looks like almost a real actor.
It's actually really good looking.
Sarras.
He did not have like a very uncanny look about him.
Come back stronger.
Show me the gameplay.
Hey everyone, I'm Gregory Loudon, Creative Director at Housemarque.
We are thrilled to announce that our latest game, Sarras, is launching next year on PS5 and enhanced for PS5 Pro.
Sarras is the ultimate evolution of the Housemarque gameplay first experience.
It's a new single-player IP that builds on Returnal's award-winning third-person action.
You play Arjun Devaraj, performed by the brilliant Rahul Kauli.
Arjun is a powerful enforcer searching for answers on a hostile, shape-shifting planet haunted by an ominous eclipse.
All of us at Housemarque can't wait to share more about Sarras, with our first look at gameplay coming later this year.
Thanks for watching.
Wow.
I'm actually interested in that one.
It looks kind of spooky.
Is that it?
Oh, Metal Gear!
Hi Snake!
No one more?
Oh, one last thing.
Oh my gosh, Darwin's Paradox.
That's it.
Show's over everybody.
Show's over.
No Death Stranding 2?
I didn't think there would be any today.
To be honest.
I think there were some cool games.
A lot of stuff I feel that I already knew about.
Or just like a lot of original titles as well.
A lot of original stuff.
Hold on.
Let's see.
Let's go to the recap.
Recap.
The Warriors game guys!
Literally right now!
Warriors Abyss.
Warriors Roguelike.
Like the directive.
Metal Gear.
Metal Gear really wasn't a surprise.
Cow Team!
Welcome to the membership!
Oh no.
Petal.
That guy.
I feel...let's see.
There was...this little?
I feel like there was so much more.
Really?
The Digimon game.
Where is that one?
It's not in here.
I was gonna say there is more, but wait.
Why didn't they...
And the FNAF game.
Yeah, wait.
Why didn't they include all the games at the end?
Wait, I'm so confused.
Why not?
Glad we got Metal Gear.
Why did you freak out and clap the whole time?
I'm sorry.
Did I clap the whole time?
Oh my gosh.
Literally the meme.
They clapped.
Everybody clapped.
I saw a snake and I clapped.
Oh no!
No way.
Gonzalo, thanks for 10 months!
Overall I feel it was kind of like...
Nothing like super groundbreaking.
Nothing super that people were like...
Except Metal Gear obviously, but...
Why don't they have all the games here?
And Darwin's Paradox.
Everybody is freaking out over that.
When the streamer has no idea how to stop.
There was a lot.
Yeah, don't get me wrong.
I wish it would show us everything.
Like a little recap.
Wait, I went straight to it.
I saw the shaggle hot and I was like wait a minute.
I know.
I know that.
I love that camera.
Wait, that angle is so great.
The shadow on Snake's face.
The philosopher.
Got it.
Yeah, did you find the gun?
I keep pausing at the wrong time.
I want to see his face.
There are so many things going on behind that head.
Colonel Titan security around this game.
Minto is coming to play it.
I'm sure of it.
No Fukura!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, have we seen him?
Where is Sokolove?
Look at this guy.
I'm telling you.
He is like 20 cursors wide.
They have made him like... He is just a wall.
He is transcendent human.
He is so beefy.
Why did they make him an actual tank?
He is so massive.
It's what I see.
There is one thing that makes me think that there is something different about Snake.
And I think this is it.
I think that they just made him like...
I mean, he has to eat those bullets somehow.
But goddammit!
He is extra solid.
No!
Snake!
Oh gosh, everybody just looks so good.
Break boss.
It's true!
Oh gosh.
I see literally every pore.
The fear.
That's my one fear.
Can you see inside the fairies?
Oh yeah, you can.
You can see him.
Oh my gosh.
He looks so good.
He has the thighs of evergreen tree trunks.
That's what I'm saying!
He is beefier than the boss.
He is a beef boss.
Wow, he looks so cool.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry, I know I'm watching it again.
Snake!
Wait, it won't let me zoom in.
No!
Oh my gosh, this is the face that I was telling you guys about earlier.
He makes such a silly face.
Well, that was fun though.
We still had a good time, I think, watching the state of play together.
Hopefully there is still at least some stuff that you are interested in.
And if not, you know, games are always coming out.
Games are always coming out.
Bro is flabbergasted.
That's so funny.
Lies of Pea.
That's Onimusha, right?
This doesn't look as good though, I'm not going to lie.
I think I prefer when they do the stupid paranormal stuff.
Endurance watching 50 plus times the trailer.
I will know every little millisecond.
Thanks for streaming on your day off.
Glad you got your delta fix.
Thank you!
Thank you, love to see you.
Oh, this is Freddy Fazbear.
Hello, where is Freddy Fazbear?
Thank you, Chai Princess.
Secret of the Mimic.
Is that based on one of the books or something?
Look at that.
Famco edging us on purpose for the Ace Combat 8 announcement.
It's only February.
We have the whole rest of the year for more announcements.
Hopefully, right?
Since it's the 30th year anniversary.
What's my favorite Metal Gear Solid game?
It's kind of flip-flops between 2 and 3.
Also, Peace Walker.
Basically, those three are on the same level.
Rip another year with no Bloodborne 2.
I'm sorry.
Let's see what else we got.
Oh yeah, It Takes Two Riders.
I'm so confused about what's going on in this game.
And then we got WWE Island.
Do I sound like I'm coping?
Do I sound like I'm coping right now?
What was this one?
Oh yeah, Sonic, right?
Oh my eyes.
Oh my god, every screenshot is literally illegible.
Except this one.
Wait, are those little ghosts?
Look at those guys.
I'm going to like them.
I cross worlds.
Oh see, this is the closest we'll get to Ace Combat.
I'm sorry everybody.
It's cool to be a Sonic fan.
Have you played the original Metal Gear on NES?
I have.
I've played all the games, but...
Snake's Revenge, and Survivor...
Survivor...
Survive and Acid.
Did I miss the Lifeline 2 announcement?
Survivor.
Look at this skinny bean over here.
This guy is literally phasing out of existence.
Let's get him some food.
They don't feed them on the base apparently.
Who is that?
Help him.
He barely made it into the video.
Oh yeah, we had the new... I guess...
I feel like the Monster Hunter Wilds trailer didn't need to be as long as it was.
The game comes out next week.
Have you tried the Sonic Racing games?
This is like the fourth title in the series.
Actually, I haven't.
The only Sonic games that I've really played were the ones for...
Like the older ones.
Oh my gosh.
I had it on my Sega Nomad.
Oh, I think we're behind some... Wait.
Unless it's a... Oh wait.
Imagine the cake that unit has.
I know.
The Sonic Ghosts are called Wisps actually?
No way!
Seriously?
You had a Nomad?
Well, it was my sister's Nomad and it was given to me, so yeah.
Technically, I had a Nomad.
But it was my sister's and then passed down to me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Anyway, this was fun.
Thank you guys.
What was this?
That elephant though.
The new Freddy Fazbear is going to be so funny.
Okay, I hope you guys had fun.
Thank you guys and I'll see you later.
Bye bye!
Otsuminto, have a good rest of your day.
Thanks for watching with me.
Thanks for letting me freak out over Metal Gear.
Bye bye!
Actually, I want to say.
I'm kind of annoyed that they then put the...
They couldn't wait like 3 days to do the trailer for Metal Gear and put it on the store then?
Why did I have to get spoiled?
You know what?
Now I'm kind of annoyed.
I could have seen that trailer for the first time today.
And instead, they put it on the store early.
Digimon also leaked?
No way!
That's so annoying.
Hey, PlayStation Store!
Anyway, okay bye!